OK, so we have just seen that
if we have a single recurrent
class, which is not periodic,
then the Markov chain reaches
steady state, and the steady
state probabilities satisfy
the following
system of equations.
These equations are essential
in the study of Markov chains,
and they have a name.
They are called the
balance equations.
In fact, it's worth
looking at them
in a somewhat different way than
how we introduced them so far.
Using a frequency
interpretation.
Along the way, it
will shed some light
on the how or why they are
called balance equations.
Intuitively, one
can sometimes think
of probabilities as frequencies.
For example, if we keep
tossing a fair coin, which
has a probability half of Heads,
and then in the long run, half
of the time we are
going to see Heads.
So let us try an interpretation
of this kind for pi
of j, the steady state
probability of state j.
Imagine the evolution
of a Markov chain
as a particle jumping
from state to state.
And imagine an observer
at a given state.
So imagine that you
have an observer here,
in a given state j.
And imagine that
this observer will
keep counting every time the
particle visits the state j.
So you have this
observer keeping
track every time the particle is
in state j and keep recording.
So, for example, one
record at time two,
and saw it at time
four, eight, maybe n.
And you can look at the
total number of time
this observer saw the
particle being in j,
and you can define it.
Let's call it y of j of n.
So yj of n represents
the total number of ones
that you have up to time n.
So it's the total
number, so we divide by n
to have the frequency.
So here that would be
the frequency of time
this observer saw the particle
in state j up to time n.
Well, when n is very,
very large, so n large,
that frequency
approaches pi of j.
In fact, we can make
it more rigorous
by saying that that
converges to pi of j
when n goes to infinity
in a rigorous fashion
that we will not discuss here.
So we have now a frequency
interpretation of pi of j.
Now, let us think
about a frequency
interpretation of
transitions from 1 to j.
So again, you have
a new observer,
and this observer
look at it here,
and every time the particle
pass here, he put a one.
So, for example, maybe
one here and here.
So if you think about it,
you're looking at from 1
to j, and of n, that would
be the total number of ones
that you observe
here up to time n.
And if you divide by 1,
that's the frequency,
and so what is this frequency?
Well, let's look at it this way.
So how often do we
have such a transition?
Well, a fraction pi1 of
the time, the particle
is in state 1, and
whenever at state 1,
there is going to be a
probability p1j of going there.
There might be other
ways to go, but out
of all the time the
particle is in state one,
the frequency of time it will
transition to j will be pi 1j.
So out of all possible
transitions that can happen,
the fraction of
these transitions
that will happen from 1 to
j will be pi 1 times p1j.
Again, this is when
n is large, and this
can be made more rigorous.
Now, what's the total frequency
of transitions into state j?
So these are
transitions leaving.
These are the transitions
of interest here.
So think about a third observer
looking here and recording
every time the particle
goes through here, here,
here, or here.
So what is the frequency
of transition here?
Well, it will be the sum of
all the possible transitions
that we have observed there.
And so this is going to be this
and that corresponds to this.
Now, the last step
of the argument
is to see that the
particle is in state j, if
and only if the last
transition was into state j.
And this explains that this
part, which we have calculated
here, will be the same as this
one and that explain that.
So this equation expresses
exactly the statement
that we made.
That's useful intuition
to have, and we
are going to see an example
later on how it gives us
shortcuts into
analyzing Markov chains.